how is having kids change her
perspective at what age were you when
you started having I I was 32 when I had
my first one uh and you got to realize I
love kids if I could have 20 kids we
just got married late and my wife is not
comfortable having more kids we were
supposed to have twins one of them
didn't make it so we made a decision
this is that we got four right now
decision was to have five we were gonna
have five Wonder to make and we got four
we're very happy but what do kids do so
think about uh Jordan Peterson said
something very interesting he says men
will not really uh lose the ability to
be selfish until you have a kid I'm prep
you know not necessarily saying it
specifically the way he said it but once
you have a kid something changes about
you because everything's about you know
I'm gonna go over do this and yeah you
love your wife but you love your wife in
a different way than you love your mom
in a different way than you love your
dad in a different way than you love
your
you know brother or sister then the way
you love your best friend and the way
you love your career then the way you
love your kid I've experienced all those
loves it's a very very different love
for your kid now having said that
somebody's going to watch us and say I'm
gonna go make a baby tonight okay I
highly discourage of doing that because
before you have a kid you have to also
know you can't be it doesn't take a lot
to make a kid it takes a lot to raise a
kid we have Shaq here so Shaq story is
an interesting one with his father where
his biological father wasn't there he
went to jail when he was born so this
other gentleman comes in who helps raise
him and there's a lot of great stories
about the way his father raised him one
time uh Shaka drinking beer at 13 years
old so his dad finds out he's drinking
beer so he goes to his dad says you want
to drink beer he says he says no I'm
just having beer dad he says no problem
come with me he has him drink to 12
Beers that night he says I hated it so
much I never touched beer ever again I
couldn't stand it now whether he had it
or not fire I mean I loved it I had so
much fun since then
but the point is you hear these stories
and you say okay at least his father
whether you want to call it stepfather
or not he was committed to wanting to
raise the leaders you have to love
raising leaders if that's not something
that you value and it's not a dream of
yours don't have kids but you know the
Jewish proverb says there's three things
every man should do okay plant a tree
write a book have a son okay because all
those three outlive you when you write a
book if you write a good book people are
going to read it when you're dead when
you plant a tree if you do it right it's
going to outlive you when you have a son
it's going to outlive you and your legs
it continues so it's a very different
Dynamic
um you officially are in two places at
the same time it's where you are and
it's wherever your kid is at if you got
two kids three different places at the
same time you're always thinking but
it's a different Dynamic that's for sure
so I have a friend Alex harmosi we had
him on the podcast and he said he would
have a hard time having a kid because
what if his kid didn't turn out to be
the type of man that he would want his
kid to be okay so great question so
let's talk about that we're on a flight
yesterday and in our family what we do
is we debate we like debate so I'll tell
the kids who's better Marvel or Avengers
one kid will say oh definitely Marvel
and the other kid will say Avenger I
said let's debater why do you think and
we'll debate for 30 minutes so yesterday
we're flying out here myself my wife uh
Sam Mario and time and the kids and we
started debate so let me ask you a
question my sons are sitting there ten
and eight I said would you rather marry
a girl who you're crazy about her more
than she's for you or would you rather
marry a girl who she's more crazy about
you yeah you should have seen what
happened first of all no joke a couple
of people on the flight I want to
mentioned started crying an hour and a
half later because it's an emotional
conversation because you go deeper and
deeper and deeper because the risk is if
you love her more and she doesn't love
you as much what if she gets bored but
then the risk is what if you marry
somebody that she loves you more but you
get bored what if you then go bored and
do something so there's a risk so here's
a moral of the story to Alex Alex is an
absolute stud of a guy and I think I
think he's a a doing a phenomenal job
for society with the message he's given
and it's a different kind of a message
but it's Crystal Clear a great teacher
he's doing a very good job I think that
guy's going to be a giant and the
content creation is already doing great
for business supporting content creation
but let me make the point to you with
what he said everything in life is a
risk you choose to get married it's a
risk you choose to stay single it's a
risk you choose to have kids you're
taking a risk you choose to not have
kids you're taking a risk there isn't
anything in life you do that's not a
risk I can choose to have been a I could
have chosen to have been a Bachelor
living in a 40 million dollar Penthouse
in in Miami and had different growths
coming every night but then I asked the
question I said so what will my Tuesday
night look like what will my weekend
look like what would my Friday night
look like at 43 what am I doing okay
cool one weekend you do it it's cool
five girls ten girls 20 girls 30 girls
then what at what like what are you
chasing are you trying to compete with
Will Chamberlain you're going after
Warren Betty what record are you trying
to break and then what if you get that
record are they going to put a frame and
a Hall of Fame saying 5293 different who
cares about that only guys in their 20s
May care about that or some other people
may care about that but some people may
care for that that's still a risk it's a
lonely life eventually okay if you end
up in that space But I've said this as
well and when it comes down to marriage
you get married if you want to have kids
your family will benefit more if you're
married instead of not being married and
there's a very clear argument for not
having kids especially today it's a very
big risk for having kids today because
if you don't have money say you have a
certain set of values like he's not in
Risk you know but certain people will be
in Risk say you have certain values that
you want to teach your kids but you
can't send your kids to a private school
your kids will go to public school what
happens if your kids go to public so how
much control and influence do you have
over what those teachers eight hours a
day will teach your kids you have this
much influence okay because you ain't
paying for it taxpayers are paying for
it right there is massive massive risk
you bring this kid here you raise them
you feed them you finance them and then
other people shape their mindset that's
a massive risk so for me the argument of
not having kids if you don't have the
money to put them in a private school
that teaches the values and principles
that you want to teach I fully
understand that argument but the idea
for Alex who can afford to have 50 kids
himself to say I don't want to have kids
because what if that kid turns out bad
he's right it's going to that's why you
don't have only one kid Alex you have
five kids and you play the odds game if
you enjoyed this video I give a keynote
a few weeks ago date is specifically on
the topic of cracking a code to content
creation if you've not seen it click
here to watch it take care everybody bye
[Music]